we've been keeping tabs on the data on
this pandemic as it's been going on
where we've come from where we may be
going
and let's just have a look at what some
of those numbers are telling us we get
those
latest death figures from the office for
national statistics and here's how they
look this shows you all the way back to
the early part of the pandemic
the number of deaths they rose very
sharply then fell down
in the summer and then rose again in
that second wave and what you can
probably just about make up let me add a
line so you can see it
is that where we are at the moment in
the second wave we haven't quite
exceeded the peaks in terms of daily
deaths
that we had in the first wave and that
might well be we might now have passed
uh the peak in this wave but what
matters is the
area beneath those lines that's the
shear total of people the death toll
in each of these waves and if we compare
the two so you take that first wave over
there that runs from
march to august more or less uh last
year then you've got the second wave
september to now
and you just take them and count all of
the deaths that we've had in each of
those waves
well here's where we are you can see
that in this wave we're in at the moment
it's about 59
700 in the first wave 57
700 so it's about 2 000 more
in this wave the second wave has a
higher death toll already
than the first wave but i mentioned we
may have some good news which is that
we might now be past the peak why do we
think that well if you have a look at
this and again
this is just the number of deaths daily
deaths that we're seeing from that ons
series and you compare it to cases so
the number of positive tests
for covert 19. the two are quite
correlated
i've moved deaths a little bit uh
forward so that you can see the two are
in line with each other and they're on
different axes but the key thing is the
shape
when cases go up deaths tend to go up
when cases go down deaths often go down
quite soon afterwards and look at what's
happened with cases they've come down
very sharply in the last few weeks that
suggests that maybe we're now past the
peak
for deaths and they're going to come
down the bad news though
is that there may well be more bad news
more deaths for a while
even if this falling cases does continue